[Musique]
faire ses études supérieures à
l'université de paris est sans doute le
rêve le plus cher aux étudiants de la
france entière
ce rêve pose des problèmes nombreux et
le plus difficile à résoudre est le
problème de leur logement
les sites universitaires de la région
parisienne coffre 7000 chambres qui
représente environ 11 % les besoins les
89 % restants doivent se soumettre au
hasard des locations temps les hôtels du
quartier latin ou chez les particuliers
en arrivant à paris l'hôtel est la
première étape on l'abandonnent souvent
parce qu'il est trop onéreux 14 services
se répartissent alors la tâche de loger
les étudiants en ville les plus
importants sont le comité parisien
la fédération et la mutuelle nationale
des étudiants de france cependant il
existe peu de contacts entre ces
quatorze service ce qui permet trop
librement
le jeu de la concurrence des prix enfin
les conditions mêmes de ce logement sont
loin d'être toujours satisfaisantes
inconfort manque de liberté de calme
sont parfois le lot de l'étudiant
abstrait un travail solitaire est
difficile il n'est plus en mesure de
fournir l'effort que les examens exige
de lui
quelle est alors la chambre de ses rêves
quant au committee vous êtes-vous
étudiants en sciences depuis combien de
temps
depuis deux ans et où l'avez-vous
actuellement dans une chambre clameur 3
euros vous êtes étudiant depuis combien
de temps je prépare une licence de
lettres modernes à la sorbonne depuis
deux ans et où le jeu vous actuellement
je vais à proximité du quartier latin
chez une logeuse assez empoisonnant qui
surveille mes allers venues qui entre
dans ma chambre à n'importe quel moment
mais celle en grenier vous êtes étudiant
de plus combien de temps c'est la
première année que je suis étudiant en
lettres et où le g20 actuel je lâche mes
parents mais une maroc deux pièces avec
mon petit frère qui tâche est embêtant
il faut bien le dire
c'est difficile pour travailler à nice
pendant ces étudiants depuis combien de
temps
si la première année de lettres que je
fais une jeep open j'habite dans un
foyer de jeunes filles quartier latin à
la lance vous êtes étudiant depuis
combien de temps
depuis un an je crois par saint cloud
lettres et ou loger vous actuellement
chez mes parents que sera alors pour
vous la chambre devant
chambre indépendante où je puisse
recevoir des visites ou ch puisse
rentrer alors que je veux sans être
surveillés surtout du calme une chambre
qui serait situé dans le quartier latin
pas la faculté pour les bibliothèques le
restaurant et surtout pour les la
faculté rapidement et puis d'autre part
une chambre qui serait assez grande de
loyer assez réduit avec l'eau
l'électricité et le chauffage
mais surtout c'est la proximité de la
faculté qui est importante
une chambre dans paris ou même d'un
proche banlieue et les commodités de
transport et surtout le calme et
civilité de être indépendante mais
évidemment ce serait d'avoir à tout prix
une chambre pour pouvoir travailler en
liberté indépendance et toutes les
facilités ne suis pas exigeant d'abord
le grand problème c'est le prix
avoir une chambre dans le loyer sera
très peu cher vivre à deux dans une
chambre ce fait est longue concessions
réciproques mais
c'est quelquefois
fort difficile aussi bien
psychologiquement que
point de tas de détails matériels alors
j'aimerais la même solution avec une
chambre seul ou bien encore une chambre
particulière n'importe où
pas trop loin du quartier latin quand
même est assez élevé c'est à dire que
j'aimerais une chambre par exemple 4e ou
5e étage il nous reste a demandé aux
responsables officiels de l'université
comment ils répondent aux problèmes qui
leur sont posées monsieur le recteur
baba vous êtes directeur du centre
national des oeuvres universitaires et
scolaires
le problème du logement étudiant est
l'un des premiers problèmes qui vous
préoccupe
pouvez vous nous dire d'abord combien
yat-il d'étudiants en france
actuellement
et bien mademoiselle lilian saumon 6 220
mille étudiants dont à peu près un quart
sont domiciliés à paris il y en aura
environ 450 milles dans cinq ans et
probablement entre 5 et 600 milles dans
dix ans c'est donc un problème
extrêmement urgent dont il faut
s'occuper au plus tôt que le logement de
tous ces étudiants et c'est même un très
grave problème si je regarde par exemple
aujourd'hui le pourcentage des étudiants
logés il ne se monte qu'à 5% alors qu'il
faudrait que nous puissions arriver à 20
% c'est-à-dire que il nous faudra
actuellement 44 me chambrent alors que
nous n'avons que dix emile il en
faudrait ce 85000 en octobre 65 et 110
milles en octobre 1969
nous sommes loin du compte si vous
voulez des chiffres il faudrait que
notre budget de construction puisse être
d'environ 20 milliards dès l'année
prochaine
je ne crois pas hélas que nous
arriverons à ce chiffre
quelle est la situation d'un étudiant
devant le jld et en dehors de sa famille
à paris et bien à paris d'étudiants
doigts qui peut se loger dans les cités
universitaires qui sont celles du
boulevard jourdan celle d'anthony celle
bientôt de bullier est également dorcé
il y à anthony en tenir
tout le monde parle à peu près dans le
monde entier qui est évidemment un
modèle de réalisations sur le plan
architectural mais qui n'est pas sans
présenter certains inconvénients en tant
que logement étudiant il y à anthony 500
jeunes filles 18 cents jeunes gens et
500 jeunes ménages qui nous ont obligés
à construire des pouponnières des
garderies d'enfants et des écoles
maternelles et ça n'est tout de même pas
notre rôle je pense au centre national
chargé de loger des étudiants de
distraire une partie de nos crédits pour
loger des tout petits enfants et assurer
leur instruction la cité à mon avis est
beaucoup trop grande elle ne permet pas
une intégration sociale de l'étudiant
autant que les étudiants eux mêmes le
désireraient et surtout elle est trop
éloignée du centre de paris il faut tout
de même compter une bonne douzaine de
kilomètres depuis anthony jusqu'à la
sorbonne étudiants hésitent à faire ce
chemin quatre fois par jour et souvent
ils ne seront pas au cours ou ici
remballe serge huet vous êtes étudiant
de plus combien de temps suit en lettres
depuis deux ans et où l'ag vous
actuellement
à la résidence universitaire d'antony
suppose que c'est pour vous alors la
chambre de vos rêves
du point de vue confort oui nous avons
une chambre avec soleil vue sur le parc
de sceaux des conditions de travail
idéales mais avec les bibliothèques sont
à côté le restaurant du restaurant
universitaire cela pose cependant un
problème précisé quels problèmes cause
de la cité d'anthony
je pense à un problème psychologique la
vie en communauté
le site n est pas construite à la mesure
de l'étudiant il ya de longs couloirs et
nous connaissons vraiment pas quels sont
vos rapports avec les autres étudiants
au très froid
nous nous rencontrons dans les couloirs
nous connaissons vraiment pas c'est un
milieu d'étudiants très fermé avec aucun
contact avec le milieu extérieur
quel serait pour vous alors la solution
idéale je pense à une cité plus à la
mesure de l'étudiant par petits
pavillons ne dépensent avec cadre
familial quelles seraient alors à votre
avis les solutions souhaitable qui
répondrait à toutes les nécessités de la
vie étudiante et bien la solution
souhaitable
évidemment c'est d'avoir des cités
universitaires qui soit à la fois à côté
de l'institut ou de la faculté de
ludothèque du laboratoire et en même
temps si tu es dans une à l'intérieur
d'une ville il faut que les étudiants
puissent se frotter si j'ose dire à
d'autres groupes sociaux que le sien il
ne fait pas son apprentissage de la vie
et de son métier de futurs conducteurs
donne uniquement sur les bancs de la
faculté
il doit fréquenter d'autres groupes
sociaux il faudra donc qu'on puisse
réaliser cette chose un pull topic
maintenant de construire des sites à
l'intérieur des villes
à côté des facultés comme nous ne
pouvons pas le faire en raison du manque
de terrains et surtout de la cherté du
terrain nous sommes obligés de sortir de
là
avec l'université je pense a dit mme à
bordeaux je pense à toulouse
je pense à dijon qui en sauront s'ils
sont en train de réaliser ou ont déjà
réalisé en partie une espèce de con puce
universitaire permet d'abord une bonne
administration et il permet ensuite à
l'étudiant de vivre une vie qui est
beaucoup plus proche de la normale que
dans une grande caserne car c'est bien
cela en réalité comme celle d'anthony je
crois que c'est la meilleure solution
ce n'est pas quelque chose que nous
avons cherché nous n'avons pas
l'intention de réaliser un campus comme
dans les pays anglo saxons je pense à
cambridge où je pense à certaines
universités des états unis mais nous
irons est ternie par la force des choses
et surtout par notre pauvreté en terrain
et en large nous avons choisi avec
nicole chardère qui tous à proposer
cette enquête de rendre visite un
étudiant barthélémy
il vous dira ses regrets ses espoirs et
ses rêves jours nicole 6h une enquête
soulagement étudiants à le logement si
tu veux te faire visiter ma chambre
alors tout d'abord tu as le balcon avec
une vue imprenable depuis notre dame
jusqu'à l'arc de triomphe
ensuite la cuisine fonctionnelle avec
ses meubles de rangement le lavabo ira
salle de bain et toros extraordinaire
une chambre de bonne
le chauffe eau enfin voici le lit qui
est le meuble principal problème à peu
près toute la place qui lors que la
chambre se trouve autour de lui ce qui
fait qu'il prend beaucoup de place pour
qualité de travail suis obligé de mettre
la machine sur un cube ce cube s'est
autrefois le cabinet de toilette de la
bonne qui habitait ici
et puis pour finir l'armoire dans
laquelle on casse tout mais forcément
n'est pas bibliothèque
tu viennes province mais depuis combien
de temps as tu à paris et comment tu
fais pour trouver cette chambre
eh bien j'ai fait mes études
effectivement avallon ensuite je suis
venu à paris où je suis en propédeutique
à la faculté des lettres et pourquoi de
l appareil il y avait sûrement un culte
et plus près le bien depuis toujours
j'ai rêvé de venir habiter paris parce
que je pense que paris c'est vraiment le
point de rencontre de la jeunesse
mais en arrivant à paris le problème du
mal logement se pose est comment l'as-tu
résolu eh bien j'ai fait comme n'importe
quel voyageur en arrivant j'étais à
l'hôtel
malheureusement l'argent quand mes
parents et celui que je gagne en donnant
des cours est insuffisant pour payer les
trois pays prend des trente mille francs
par mois de l'hôtel alors je dis aux
coups par au service les bureaux du
logement et pendant un mois environ
j'ai essayé de trouver une chambre mais
celle qu'on proposait étaient trop
éloignées du quartier latin ou alors
elle cédé trop cher et j'ai trouvé je
finis par tous mais cette chambre par
des relations que penses tu de cette
chambre présente elle des inconvénients
elle présente quelques inconvénients par
exemple il y à la suivre sur les toits
de paris qui rentre à la fois par le
balcon et vue par la fissure du mur
ensuite elle et moi je vous fais c'est à
dire j'ai un petit réchaud électrique
qui marche mais qu'il faut guère leur
l'hiver et l'été elle est trop fou fait
parce que c'est le toits de zinc qui est
vraiment brûlant alors l'été fut obligé
de sortir de travail et sera opéré du
pouce huileries soit à la bibliothèque
quand il ya de la place mais si tu as
choisi cette chambre s'est tout de même
parce qu'elle présentait quelques
avantages
oui elle présente l'avantagé d'être dans
un immeuble
c'est à dire qu'on a un contact avec des
gens qui ne sont pas des étudiants avec
ses voisins quels sont tes rapports et
bien ne sont pas un intime mais ils sont
très cordiaux c'est à dire que par
exemple au 21 il ya l'électricien
parfois ils m'aident à me dépanner quand
c'est un an
et que mon courant ou alors au 19
il ya une famille entière qui habitent
là et c'est agréable de d'avoir une vie
de famille près de soi cas peut-être pu
remarquer d'ailleurs dans le couloir les
jouets et les enfants en somme pour toi
la chambre de bonne de paraître est la
solution idéale donc tu celui d alain
c'est pas encore ça c'est à dire que il
faut pas nécessaire que la chambre soit
sous le toit mais je crois qu'il est
important que la chambre se trouve dans
un immeuble avec où tu peux voir des
gens qui ont une autre vie que la tienne
par exemple j'aurais très bien pu
habiter dans une cité étudiante avoir
une belle forme avec des douches ou au
restaurant universitaire en bas mais
j'ai préféré habiter ici pour ne pas
vivre toujours dans le même milieu et
puis je crois que l'essentiel surtout
c'est d'avoir ça vu ses murs franc
soleil et puis d'être indépendants ainsi
être étudiant c'est aussi être
philosophe au sens le plus quotidien du
mot
[Musique]